Speaker 1: Let's go next to how about John
from Sacramento?
John, welcome.
Speaker 3: And hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: So I think every David Pakman scans.
Speaker 3: Worst nightmare happened to me
last time I called in.
The mike didn't work.
I was panicking frantically trying to get
the buttons to work.
Nothing did.
So I'm elated that it worked out.
Speaker 1: I share in the elation with you.
Speaker 2: So I'm an absolute.
Speaker 3: Political layman.
Speaker 2: And I had this crazy idea I wanted
to run by you.
Just get your opinion, please.
So I looked at the Second Amendment after
you've already.
Speaker 3: Got really depressed as like, man,
this is what can we do?
Yep.
And I thought about the first part and I.
Speaker 2: Thought and thought.
And so I was outside the DMV, and I was like,
That's it.
Speaker 3: What if we had a department of
militia regulation?
And that department said, okay, we get to
decide who can be in the militia or not.
I think level one, you can be a hunter.
So any bolt action rifles, sure.
You're in the militia.
Speaker 2: You can go get that at your store
all you want.
Moving to level two.
Speaker 4: Well, that's assault rifles.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
25 year old in the militia.
And then we just.
Speaker 2: Set that up because right now,
Biden's not fulfilling.
Speaker 3: His constitutional obligation.
He's got to have that regulated militia.
Speaker 2: So I don't know.
What are your thoughts on something crazy
like that?
Speaker 1: Listen, you're thinking too rationally.
And here's the reality.
And the Supreme Court has found that the Second
Amendment applies to an individual right to
have a firearm.
So the focus on the militias, it's not actually
relevant, unfortunately.
I mean, I think it's a great idea what you're
saying.
I think it should be applied just more generally
to gun safety regulations.
But no, if you if you did exactly what you're
suggesting, the reaction would be to rightly
say the Supreme Court already found that there
is an individual right to a gun outside of
any militia.
We don't need to be regulated as militias.
Speaker 2: Do you think I would.
Speaker 3: Push another case to the Supreme
Court if you tried to do that?
And there would be well, I guess with this
court, but I.
Speaker 1: Just don't think it would happen
to be told, I don't want to bum you out, John,
but I just don't think it would go anywhere.
Speaker 3: Well, but listen, you're thinking.
Speaker 1: Of the right things, which are
we need to take control of the situation.
We just have to find a way to do it legally.
Speaker 3: All right.
Speaker 2: David, I appreciate you taking
my call.
Speaker 1: All right.
There is John with a very important question
that we are going to continue looking into.